[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
ugh
[Applause]
you okay
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wonder
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
sorry stephen
[Music]
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
it doesn't seem fair
[Music]
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
it's pretty unfathomably exciting where
we're going in this film
it's the most fantastic new phase of
marvel
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous
in this story we are leaping into
different universes but unlocking the
multiverse creates a big pandora's box
you open the doorway and we don't know
who or what will walk through it
we're in unknown territory
i think audiences are going to be
startled these other realities invite a
plethora of all these new characters
[Music]
telling the stories was such a gigantic
endeavor
it had to be large because it had to not
only paint a picture of our universe but
of multiple universes
we need your help it was a great
opportunity to pair two of the most
powerful superheroes together
it's got a sort of darker tone to it
than with sam remy at the helm he's a
master of that
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool i
mean that really was our goal we wanted
to give the fans what they wanted just
not exactly what they expected
the stakes are real he's literally
coming up against versions of himself
things just got out of hand
[Music]
what is grief
if not love
persevering
part of the madness of the multiverse is
we get to see different realities and we
see different versions primarily of
doctor strange but we do see other
versions of wanda maximoff
i think wandavision was this journey of
her for the first time taking her own
life into her own hands and it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie i could use an avenger there
are other avengers i'll get you back in
the lunchbox
what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the one division
fans and take them to the next level
with the character they love it was fun
just looking at it from a different
perspective
the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance
with a very powerful character
in the multiverse there are alternate
versions of everyone it gives the
characters unique opportunity to meet
themselves to recognize qualities that
they may have been blind you
the fate of the multiverse depends on us
[Music]
sam raimi's dr strange and the
multiverse of madness that is a dream
come true
[Music]
i got a call from my agent saying that
kevin feige and the marvel team were
looking for a director
for the new doctor strange movie and i
was a big fan of the first one it was
really intelligent and interesting so
when that offer came and i thought this
would be a really good challenge ready
to go
[Music]
sam is such a lovely human being and
obviously he's standing in this industry
and this genre in particular is
legendary as it should be
sam has become known for this
terrorizing cinema experience
he's creating as much tension as
possible for the audience just ready for
them to have that jump scare moment
and that was always where we were headed
with the sequel to doctor strange
knowing that we wanted to explore the
mind-bending frightening side of the
multiverse
we need your help it's what what do you
know about the multiverse
telling the story is such a gigantic
endeavor and there's a lot of
dimensionalized visuals that we use in
telling that story
we shot it with an eye toward that so i
think it's going to be a very exciting
experience to go to 3d
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you